tom morello low he's coming in what's up
yeah how are you welcome welcome welcome
thanks how are you doing me I'm all
right me sidle up people Jim is
extremely excited to talk to you
primarily about Kissin Black Sabbath
well kiss because you and I wanted to go
dance about both paying gig to go to
that and I just I couldn't go to what to
the induction kisses induction which was
at the Barclays center which you were a
part of I was it was a it was a epic
night did you get a picture with all
four of them I did I got you understand
that it's been year what year was that
there's like three years ago okay yeah
literally not only we've had members
have kissed and gene and has been in
studio and Juma has brought it up to him
hey if I'd gone to that if I canceled my
gig I couldn't have gotten a picture
with the for you right and Gina's like
of course you could have yeah and Jim
every time - my [ __ ] stomach I'm so
stupid
how did you get that how did they come
to ask you they did not at the they did
not ask me the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame I was a harsh critic of the Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame and because it
didn't include many of my favorite bands
especially in the hard rock and metal
genre Sabbath and and - Jon Landau is
credit who's Bruce Springsteen's manager
one of the guys that runs it I was on I
was touring with Bruce Springsteen and I
was just laying in the John every day
about the legitimacy of the Hall based
on the exclusion of these acts and to
his credit he put me in the room and let
me be in on the panel that helps decide
the ballot and I went in there and told
him they were screwing up and if you
want to have because like if you're a
baseball player you know a kid you're a
baseball player your great dream would
be to one day be in the Baseball Hall of
Fame sure you do all the right things if
you're a kid and you're like play rock
and roll guitar you hate the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame because it doesn't I
mean your favorite bands and hey that's
a Dane trite right and to their credit
they heard my words and I put and you
know since then rush and kiss and Stevie
Ray Vaughan a number of our other
artists which had previously been
excluded are now in the Hall so does it
become difficult when you're an outward
critic of something like that could
you've been an outward critic of
everything that you are critical of for
your life sure but when it changes right
and you are then kind of responsible for
telling your fan base like no no it's
cool now yeah tell them I'm not telling
people can decide whether it's cool or
not I just thought that I like the idea
of there being a Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame and of having something to aspire
to that's like that and and so it needed
in my view we just need to be steered so
that was a more legitimate Rock like you
know I think it is it is more that you
can't even the harshest and metal
critics yes I want Motorhead and Judas
Priest and Iron Maiden to be in the rock
wall thing though Andy yes sure I want
them all to be and dude you know but at
least those bands are now part of the
conversation whereas they protect
Sabbath 10 years to get in which grace
that's what really term you should take
us off the ballot yeah so how did you
end up going from being in that seat to
being the guy who inducted kiss oh um
well I mean I made a passionate speech
for kiss in the room and then they for
the first time got on the ballot and
they easily got in once they were on the
ballot and you know people that heard my
speech in the room thought that probably
I should be the guy who conducted a just
said say some of that stuff for us oh
the band doesn't pick you I thought that
the band I think I think the band may
can't have something to do with it but
it was pretty obvious didn't you know
the speech was kind of already written
so yeah at what point do you've been a
kiss fan on your life oh yeah it was my
first favorite band my first concert on
it when did you meet them for the first
time 96 and when they were doing the
reunion rehearsals for the reunion tour
rage against machine and kiss who people
didn't know had reformed we're
rehearsing the same place and I heard
him down the hallway and I heard like
Paul's family sing and come on and love
me and I'm like I think that's Paul
Stanley so I just waited in the hall
like holy crap it's all of them so I was
on that you knew before they even
announced it oh yeah yeah for months I
mean they were I saw him every day
where'd you see them for the first I saw
them when I was a kid I think cheap
trick was opening for them it was
probably 79 at the garden I saw in 77 in
the Chicago
did you there's a rock and roll over tor
yeah so when when you get into like what
especially when you start you know when
rage starts to really pick up and become
a really relevant band right and you
start to meet your heroes you have to
try to play it cool and be like hey
we're peers you know or do you just not
allow yourself all the way I'm a super
fan and I've and never you know
eventually you get over the fan like I
Brandon a gene at the airport the other
day let's go like what's up bro like
like you know no yeah yeah yeah yeah yes
but but you know I've I had the great
opportunity to meet a lot of my record
collection you know as a kid and and you
know at first I you I give them their
due you know and I'm not trying to be
cool about it I'm a I'm still a fan
whether it was Rob Halford or whether it
was Joe Strummer or Chuck D who I play
in a band with now you know they've been
important to me so are you surprised
when they know you like it when somebody
you like grew up loving is a fan of what
you do I gotta tell you there was one
moment where I was you know there's
different people who said very you know
nice things through the years but I was
it's at a Judas Priest oh in San
Bernardino and I just stand in the
hallway you know waiting to go watch
them on stage and the band's coming down
and KK downing goes that's yeah that
never gets old
well that was I was pretty exciting for
me pretty exciting do you which brings
us to why we're here which is I have a
record out can we talk about that I'll
happily it's on metal all day long but I
want to at least let your your listeners
know what all of this meant all of my
kiss speeches and all of my metal bright
at KK Downing's love me has led to this
moment and this uh the Atlas underground
to new solo album it's out next Friday
to 12th and I guess I'm gonna guess
iTunes and stuff yeah it's coming out as
ever record it's vinyl it's it's CD it's
everywhere we're streaming services
everywhere everything is now and and
that you know in throughout my career
I've collaborated with countless people
whether it's in my bands Rage Against
the Machine
Audioslave prophets of Rage the Bruce
Springsteen an Eastern Band and a lot of
a myriad of other collaborations but
this record is a solo record but it's a
collaborative record I want it a very
the ambition to create a new genre of
rock and roll music something that has
like all of the big riffing Sabbath
esque power of what I like to do but
Melvin it with huge EDM drops and some
of the electronic wizardry of 2018 and
so the idea was to take you know in a
way to kind of be a Trojan horse and in
the same way that Hendrix like like I
described this record is the Hendrix of
now not because it has blues 10-minute
long blue solos but but the one things
that Hendrix did was he exposed an
entire generation to otherworldly guitar
playing because he had songs on the
radio it wasn't just that he dressed
cool and lit his guitar on fire it was
foxy lady and crosstown traffic and wind
cries Mary the people are like in the
midst of all these kind of jangly songs
on the radio there was this one some of
the craziest [ __ ] you ever heard that's
part of the idea with this record and
whether it's collaborations with wu-tang
clan big boy killer mike marcus mumford
portugal a man knife party Bassnectar
there's from the world of hip-hop EDM
and punk rise against Steve Aoki
I found this cast of characters to help
me make a record that is really like
this it's a rock and roll version of for
2018 so you'd never been found yourself
in a position where you're kind of
shying away from genres meaning like
this is not what I do I don't understand
no we stick to what we do it seems like
you kind of yeah I really been a
collaborative yeah and I've always been
open mind I'm from from the like I grew
up loving metal and then when you know
my friends and I found punk rock music
all the rest of them left metal alone
because they're like they're now they're
now you don't like metal a more casually
I was like I can like Motley Crue and
The Clash at the same time right um and
then hip-hop that was very divisive as
well like I loved NWA and Public Enemy
and and never left that behind fanboys
showing our age that we know that they
had there that one video I forget what
the song was was pretty pretty amazing
but but I was never a fan of EDM music
of early smite what my understanding of
it was till a metal friend of mine
turned me on to a group called knife
party and I listen knife I'm like that's
not that is is that's kicking my ass
like a great Rage Against the Machine
song
it had the heaviness and the tension and
the release and like the aggression I
was like okay hold on that's a I want to
find out more about that end of the
spectrum and what if we replace their
synthesizers with my electric guitar but
look at but sort of go through their
lens I thought that there's no music
like that and to me as a this is my 17th
studio record that I've made and it's
super exciting to me to push myself as
an artist and as a guitarist do you look
back at any age stuff and go like oh I
don't like that like as a stand if I
look back in a lot of my jokes like oh I
don't listen I'm not like putting on the
UM I just don't look for it you know let
see I feel if it comes on the radio or
something I'll check it out and sort of
give my thoughts but like you know Mike
man I got kid I got two young boys and
they're they I've never exposed them to
Rage Against the Machine like they they
have they like Metallica they like the
Hamilton something like all this stuff
but and so one day we're driving to
school and sleep now in the fire comes
on comes on the radio and I just don't
say I don't say a word I kind of turn it
up a little bit and sort of watching in
the rear view mirror and the song as I'm
like so what'd you guys think of that my
oldest son goes you eight he goes dad
that was good
what was that I'm like I'm not sure
careful doesn't matter do you go through
moments where you're like I wish we
could get rage back together and go on
that are you happy I don't if I had had
my druthers Rage Against the Machine
would have made a record every six
months from 1992 till now right that's
not what it is all right if Rage Against
the Machine show breaks out count me
when you came back for the first time it
was such an amazing show but like I went
there to see you yeah and then I had a
full panic attack the moment you guys
came out and I had to fist fight my way
out of 60,000 feet
it was the most tight my chances ever
yeah it's an intense crow
but you guys all get along so yeah yeah
I get along don't play show what do you
think it is about that band specifically
like we talk about it on the show that
the the kind of rock rap genre is looked
at it almost like I don't wanna see
people goof on it right now and because
it's awful right yep yep okay 98 point
non Rage Against the Machine ban ISM hot
ribs but rage for some reason completely
maintains you put rage on now I mean the
same way Audioslave does the same way
all your bands do I guess maybe it's you
but but it might be autism but there's
nothing about rage that feels dated like
you said when you saw it when you see
them it doesn't feel like oh it's a
reunion act it still feels relevant not
just the lyrics but in the music and
everything I'm not gonna argue with that
I thought you know we think why do you
think that I mean in in part it's like
it why it was made like that was a band
that made me we put that band together
without with absolutely zero commercial
ambition like it was a bit was a you
know a neo socialist multi-ethnic punk
metal rap band that there was none of
that on the radio
none of it playing the Hollywood clubs
it was just like we just made music we
never thought we'd be able to book a
club gig right there was no Club for
that and then then much to our surprise
it connected with people around the
world I think it was just made so
authentically you know in that and it
stands apart in that regard and I've
tried really really I made one record
before Rage Against the Machine with
this other band called lockup and in
that band we did everything that
everybody told us to do and you know the
A&R guy and the manager and the record
company and we're just trying to be
record makers and rock star and it's
just in the record didn't sound very
good and it and we got dropped and I was
named in the record it was we'd had the
may perhaps the worst name of any record
released by people it was called
something [ __ ] in this way comes
yes yes there was no apostrophe after
the end of course it was a top 10 worst
things and so when that band got dropped
you know they gave us a thousand dollars
just split between four guys is like
your severance pay and and I thought I
had my grab at the brass ring I'm done
I'm not gonna be a record maker or a
rock star so I've made a solemn vow
remember nothing [ __ ] in that way came
nothing yeah very little [ __ ] in that
case did any of those guys want to do
anything else do they all good yeah one
guy when one guy made a couple records
after that a band called extra fancy and
Atlantic but uh but it was I was done so
I made a solemn vow remember like it
might remember like the band breaking up
I was sitting in my living room and in
my apartment in West Hollywood I said
well if I'm not gonna make records I'm
gonna bow to myself to never play
another note of music that I don't
believe in and I'm just gonna play music
that I love and that's it and that's it
yeah and then I you know the first rage
record was those ideas that I didn't I
didn't expect anyone to like except for
me and my friends and I from that record
to this rack from the second record to
the 17th record that's what I've been
doing and whether it was you know with
rage or with Chris Cornell and
Audioslave or rhythms with my
Nightwatchman records which were kind of
more the folk Americana vibe or with
this Atlas underground record its
unapologetic its uncompromising it's
exactly what I want it to be I hope
people love it if they don't that's fine
so you don't look back at anything going
wow I wish I don't like this because
you're doing what you want to do yeah
exactly yeah not nothing you know did
you know Chris was depressed I guess you
did right I wouldn't define it like that
I mean he was he had demons as the way
that I would describe it and and he was
able to harness those demons to make
some of the greatest rock and roll or
anybody ever made without those demons
he doesn't he isn't that guy singer and
lyricist and so fortunately you know if
there's any silver lining to the that
horrible dark cloud it's that we get to
enjoy that music forever that he
suffered to make right so it's like the
thing that makes you great is also the
thing that eventually [ __ ] yeah yeah
are you surprised at how much sort of
Maine how mainstream political rebellion
has become like I feel I mean not only
in the sense that everybody like Trump
being the president everybody that's a
normal mainstream conversation now but
you literally have Barack Obama getting
behind a socialist candidate yeah yeah
like it's kind of wild based on the fact
that like rage was so yeah
left-of-center over here right the now
it's starting to yeah well I mean I
think that's one of the one of the
reasons why in culture it's important to
move the goalposts you know when we show
people that there's like I remember when
I listen to the Public Enemy in the
class
I lived on I grew up in a very very
conservative suburb of Chicago and the
ideas that were on those records felt
true to me and they felt like very
different from what my teachers were
saying and what the newscasters were
saying and it made me realize that
there's ideas beyond the ones that have
been spoon-fed me my whole life and I
think Rage Against the Machine provided
that for a global audience is like
here's a different set of ideas that
we're the four of us are not alone in
believing it's like our you know our
experience and the stuff we've read on
things that we've lived there's millions
of other people that feel this way but
nobody else has put this on a record and
so here it is you know here's a
different mirror to hold up to your life
and your society and it's amazing that a
lot of the guys you're collaborating
with on the solo album we all have
similar stories where they've all got
stuff to say and that's right care Mike
is becoming huge that's right here like
advocates yeah yeah and the the the
thematic thread that runs through this
Atlas underground record is social
justice ghost stories and you know when
you're working it's like 20
collaborators on this record I wanted
there to be the musical thread of kind
of creating this new alloy of rock and
roll and hard EDM and the lyrical thread
of telling the stories of like fallen
heroes and martyrs from the past to
inform the struggles of the present and
with the hope that it lights a fire
under an audience to help shape a more
just inhumane future